Trascrizione:
(Inglese): Qui a Hammam al-Alil
forniamo fuoco e supporto
alle forze irachene
che combattono per liberare
Mosul dall'Isis.
Sulla prima linea!
È appena arrivato un razzo,
un razzo è piombato sulle -
C'è il morto qua vicino,
ma fa finta di -
Mi chiamo Gabriele Micalizzi,
e sono un fotoreporter.
Faccio un mestiere complicato.
Sono nato a Milano,
anche se ho origini molto del sud.
Ho incominciato la mia carriera
perché avevo una predisposizione,
una fortissima passione
per le arti visive.
Ho incominciato
coi graffiti, poi i tatuaggi,
e poi sono arrivato
alla fotografia e al video.
Sono cresciuto non lontano da qui,
in via Rizzoli 31, Cascina Gobba.
Un posto che, negli anni '90,
era molto duro:
i vecchi giocavano nelle bische, a dadi;
e invece noi ragazzi
andavamo a fare a botte
con chi non faceva parte del blocco.
La mia prima vera esperienza in guerra
l'ho fatta in Afghanistan:
avevo ventitré anni,
non sapevo niente dell'Afghanistan.
sono andato "embedded"
con l'esercito italiano e francese.
Pensavo di vedere le scene
che avevo visto nei film,
tipo Apocalypse Now:
esplosioni ovunque,
di vedere gente che moriva straziata,
nelle trincee.
E invece non vidi nulla di tutto questo.
Passavo molto tempo a girare coi soldati,
andare a incontrare i capi tribù,
a visitare gli ospedali
che avevano costruito.
Però lì ho capito perché,
parlando di equilibrio,
anche i soldati, per rimanere lì,
avevano bisogno
di instaurare dei rapporti,
e quindi di fare qualcosa
per la popolazione.
Quindi, per mantenere l'equilibro,
tutti dobbiamo scendere a compromessi.
E stavo camminando a piedi,
e un soldato, a un certo punto,
spiana il fucile in mezzo al campo
e io mi metto davanti a lui.
Dopo la terza foto, comincia a farmi così,
e io non capivo.
Mi chiedo, perché fa così?
Stai fermo, ti devo fotografare.
Lui mi fa: "Ci sono le mine.
Torna indietro, ci sono le mine".
Quindi quella è stata
la prima cosa che ho imparato.
Perché questo mestiere
lo si impara sul campo:
non ci sono libri, non ci sono corsi,
niente di tutto ciò:
ci devi provare.
Qualche anno dopo
mi sono trovato in Thailandia,
a coprire la rivoluzione
delle Camicie rosse,
a Bangkok.
Lì ho avuto il mio battesimo del fuoco:
mi è arrivata la prima
granata, molto vicina.
È esplosa, questa granata:
un tuono che ha squarciato
veramente le strade.
E mi è caduto un ragazzo,
un ragazzo mi è caduto addosso,
Perdeva del sangue.
Io l'ho appoggiato per terra,
ho visto che non era grave,
e l'ho fotografato,
nonostante tutto il turbinio di emozioni
che mi attraversava.
E allora ho capito
che potevo fare questo mestiere,
Era adatto a me.
Pensate alla guerra come a un teatro
dove ognuno ha la sua scena, il suo ruolo.
Le sue battute.
Pensate ai pittori di guerra
prima di noi, prima dei fotoreporter.
Ognuno ha questo ruolo
che deve rispettare.
I militari usano questo termine
quando parlano di zone
di conflitto: il teatro.
perché appunto, sembra quasi
una grande messa in scena.
E il fotoreporter lì cerca di raccontare,
raccontare muovendosi
in questa ragnatela di contatti capillare.
E ha solo un'arma,
la sua macchina fotografica;
e i colpi sono le sue skills,
l'esperienza indiretta,
in guerra.
Ed è una cosa normale,
perché non è che voi andate in guerra:
la sentiamo dagli altri.
Ce la raccontano, la guerra.
Però, una cosa ve la posso
raccontare io direttamente:
in guerra si rischia tanto.
Le esperienze indirette
che si hanno in guerra, appunto,
ci portano poi a raccontare,
a noi reporter,
quando andiamo lì invece
per portare a voi i racconti,
ci causano appartenenza,
attaccamento a queste storie:
viviamo con queste persone,
diventano nostri amici,
diventano tutto per noi,
perché è una cosa
che non riusciamo a dimenticare,
quando torniamo:
chissà come sta,
chissà cosa stan facendo,
quella famiglia,
quella storia che ho seguito.
Perché le emozioni umane
in guerra accelerano,
le amicizie si cementano,
e la solidarietà diventa
la priorità di tutti.
Però devo ammettere anche questo:
che la guerra è molto fotogenica, molto.
Noi cerchiamo di raccontare, appunto,
le storie normali di queste persone
e le conseguenze del conflitto,
queste persone
che devono fare qualsiasi cosa
per proteggere la famiglia
e recuperare un pezzo di pane,
per recuperare la benzina per spostarsi.
Ma oggi, con la bulimia dei social,
tutto viene passato in questo scrollare,
anche le nostre foto finiscono là in mezzo
e si perdono, non c'è tempo
di acquisire nulla.
Il cinema ha creato miti, ha creato icone.
Pensiamo ai film:
"Full Metal Jacket",
"Black Hawk Down", "Platoon".
Pensiamo ai miti
che ne sono usciti, poi,
le figure di riferimento:
il colonnello Kurtz,
il sergente Hartman.
Oppure, Rambo:
in Libia quante gente abbiamo visto
con la doppia fila di proiettili
a X, come Rambo.
Quindi, a un certo punto,
il cinema e la realtà
hanno perso l'equilibrio.
La realtà influenzava il cinema;
il cinema, a un certo punto,
ha influenzato la realtà.
Quindi l'equilibrio si è spostato.
Pensate alla TV: la TV cos'ha creato?
La coscienza estetica delle persone.
Pensate se, negli anni '70,
un qualsiasi soldato
si fosse andato a lamentare
con una copertina di "Time",
o "Life", che usciva
se aveva la camicia messa male.
Oggi i guerrieri postano le proprie foto,
e vogliono essere trattati
come influencer:
vogliono vedersi cool
e vogliono le foto ritoccate.
Prendiamo tutto questo
come un fenomeno antropologico.
Tutto cambia; il mondo cambia;
il modo di raccontare la guerra cambia.
Siamo tutti coinvolti,
e nessuno di noi è assolto.
È una bilancia dove l'equilibrio
è su un piano inclinato.
Quando raccontiamo queste storie
proviamo a essere invisibili,
ci perdiamo, dobbiamo passare osservati.
E tutto questo va in contrapposizione
con quello che succede oggi, no?
Instagram, questo secolo
dove tutti sono protagonisti
e nessuno c'ha un cazzo da dire.
però abbiamo sempre
un'idea lontana della guerra,
è tutto là, la guerra.
Quando parliamo,
la guerra è una cosa
che non ci toccherà mai.
Però in realtà col Covid
tutti noi ci siamo resi conto
che la paura può venire molto vicina,
e quello che succede là può arrivare qua.
Quindi, mentre cerchiamo di sopravvivere
e di raccontare, comunque,
nel nostro lavoro, la follia umana,
dobbiamo comunque controllare
le nostre emozioni,
perché il segreto è quello,
controllare le emozioni.
Anche quando vedi dei sacchi
pieni di pezzi di bambini.
Perché vi dico questo?
Perché io sono padre, ho due figlie.
E quando fotografo a Gaza -
Ho fotografato questo padre
con sua figlia in grembo:
ovviamente dentro di me
c'era un vuoto incolmabile,
c'era un'emozione forte,
c'era un senso di odio,
di schifo per questa società.
Però in realtà noi facciamo questo:
raccontiamo, siamo dei veicoli.
Perché alla fine, l'uomo
è brutale come la natura:
la natura è brutale,
ma non la giudichiamo.
Pensiamo che con le foto
possiamo cambiare il mondo,
ma non è così.
Dobbiamo solo fare una cosa:
accettarlo.
Quindi ciò che succede
a mille chilometri di distanza
può effettivamente colpirci,
può effettivamente arrivare qua,
può effettivamente influenzarci?
Sì.
Quindi, quando manca
l'equilibrio in una guerra,
ci sono dei posti, dei vuoti
che vanno colmati.
E la guerra è un grandissimo
ascensore sociale.
Ad esempio, ho conosciuto
e fotografato Givi,
uomo di 35 anni,
operaio di una ditta di molle
che poi è diventato il grande condottiero
del Battaglione Somalia,
che distrusse completamente
l'aeroporto di Donetsk
e scacciò il nemico ucraino.
Oppure ho conosciuto anche Khalifa Haftar,
che era stato abbandonato
dal colonnello Gheddafi
dopo la guerra in Ciad,
buttato in una prigione,
e la CIA lo ha ripescato, riciclato,
per utilizzarlo, adesso, in una ribalta
che dura ancora oggi in Libia.
Quando ci sono delle crisi di governo,
bene o male lo stato
deve cercare
di mantenere la minima sovranità basilare,
quindi i confini devono essere
comunque tenuti,
gli ospedali devono funzionare, a volte.
Ma la legge incomincia a vacillare,
la corruzione dilaga
e le maglie si aprono.
Quindi pura anarchia,
ed è in queste maglie buie
che io mi muovo per raccontare.
Ma parliamo anche un po' dell'economia.
In guerra ci vogliono
un sacco di soldi per girare,
per raccontare
e andare a vedere le storie,
trovarle, muoversi.
E anche le persone coinvolte
devono usare un sacco di soldi,
ci vuole un sacco di cash.
Perché quando un paese è in guerra
la sua moneta si svaluta,
tutti i business
si creano in quel momento,
c'è un sacco di business,
non c'è miglior posto al mondo
per fare business della guerra.
Tutto diventa un commercio:
i viveri, la benzina, come dicevamo;
oppure i favori,
i documenti, i passaggi.
Quando ero a Baghuz,
prima che mi ferissero,
stavo seguendo, appunto,
la situazione nell'ultima sacca dell'Isis,
e avevo sentito di questa storia
che, praticamente,
chi voleva scappare dallo stato islamico,
da questo stato fantasma,
comprava questo passaggio
da dei contrabbandieri.
I contrabbandieri ti prendevano,
per il compenso di mille euro a persona,
e ti portavano verso la Turchia;
ma in realtà, appena usciti
dai confini dello stato islamico,
ti portavano dagli americani e dai curdi.
Quindi doppio pagamento.
Cazzo, questo è fare
business creativo, ragazzi.
Quindi oggi utilizziamo
le vite delle persone
ma le abbiamo sempre usate,
la guerra è questo, no?
L'interesse schiaccia tutto.
Quindi, per muovere
questo equilibrio, sulla bilancia
si appoggia una moneta
e non più un'ideologia.
Per raccontare una storia
ci sono tanti punti di vista,
tante diverse angolature e sfaccettature:
i luoghi, gli spazi.
Ovunque nel mondo
può essere il Medio Oriente:
cerchiamo di raccontare con metodo,
e io è con metodo che ho imparato,
stando in giro per il mondo.
Adesso sto seguendo
una storia qua, a Milano,
precisamente in via della Moscova.
In una caserma fatiscente,
c'è il nucleo investigativo
della squadra omicidi.
Questo gruppo, che ha
un ranking incredibile,
100% di omicidi risolti,
qualche cold case ancora da risolvere,
ma comunque un ranking pazzesco,
il migliore in Italia e in Europa.
Ho seguito il caso Alves -
il caso Alves è un omicidio efferato,
83 coltellate a questo
transessuale brasiliano.
E lì ho capito che comunque,
anche a Milano -
Lo sapevo già, ma ho capito
che comunque la criminalità
è fluida, a Milano,
si muove segue un po'
questa economia marciante,
si intreccia,
questa Milano che vediamo
da grattacieli illuminati, patinata,
in realtà la notte si trasforma,
e si discosta da quello che è
il naviglio, il tram, l'aperitivo,
ma diventa l'omicidio di via Plana.
Questo territorio che noi
cerchiamo di esplorare,
che è lontano come la guerra
o come la città, che è qui,
la nostra città, la mia città.
Alla fine io ci provo, a calarmi
nei meandri della psiche umana
e ragionare su questo equilibrio
tra la follia e la lucidità.
Abbiamo esperienze diverse,
e probabilmente le routine di tutti noi
a volte pensiamo siano
normali, irrilevanti.
Però tutti noi possiamo imparare una cosa,
e abbiamo il dovere di farlo:
capire la differenza
tra il bene e il male.
Quindi, questo mio racconto
può fare due cose:
spaventarvi o insegnarvi qualcosa,
come ha insegnato a me.
Quindi, parlando di equilibri,
direi che l'equilibrio
è su un piano inclinato,
la scelta di capire, o ignorare,
sta a voi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)